we got the rock Ally I'll jump this off
with me first because I'm being solved
obviously have it and then you know Alex
hasn't seen it and King will be getting
it shortly but um look it's out it's out
in these streets you know a lot of
people have now have their hands on the
device you know we know Xbox has kind of
been behind it but I'll start off with
me you know I'll get off the the rip
let's let's get to the good you know
actually I actually want to get to the
bad first let me get to the bad first
you know this is a Windows device
through and through this is a Windows 11
device if you come in there thinking
this is switch energy and everything is
going to be so easy and accessible to
move around no you gotta do your Windows
updates you got to do your assets um
Asus uh my Asus app updates Windows
store updates you know make sure you
treat it as if it's a PC first another
thing I would highly recommend is the
little shortcut keys in the back if you
use those in conjunction with the
directional pad you can pull up the
keyboard easier so that you could type
stuff like that if you're the guy that's
not going to use a home I've been USB
stuff so that part you can tell from a
UI standpoint there is Jank it's a
learning period you know what I mean so
I will say that
um another thing I would say
first person is amazing Fighters
it's solid but I wouldn't say high
competitive I wouldn't say like I
wouldn't use this if I'm really doing
some online some tournament place thing
because sometimes it's a little
sensitivity with this I forgot what this
is called not the traditional Saudi
Style d-pad with this part right here
these Corners are attached so that's my
little nitpick there some your movements
are gonna come out but if you want
extreme preciseness I wouldn't recommend
it for high competitive play and the
last thing just like the steam deck the
battery life
that battery life is no joke man you
gonna go through some joints so if
you're playing these high demanding
games Next Generation games you will go
through So eventually you got your ally
battery pack or you know you got an AC
joint
um those are the probably the most
things I would say for bad as far as bad
you know but again just the fact it's
Windows 11. now let's get to the good
now as far as that
this is the best playing experience of
video games on a handheld period period
like when it comes to
let's just say the entire
putting like first of all we already
know how I feel about the offset analogs
with the Xbox controller so FPS is god
tier on this like that is amazing and I
think what what people want to really
get at home when they get a hold of this
device is they're going to see how it
controls second of all 1080p 120 hertz
vrr in the Box you know
the best sound you've ever heard on a
handheld this is Dolby Atmos at its
finest to the point I got to turn this
thing down this thing is sounding like
an orchestra is going on you can also um
and it has the free license with it you
can also use it in a headset unless it's
coming from a person that has a steam
deck oh yes this is not even steam deck
is that picture gameplay playing games
picture and sound it's not close like
this is beating steam deck on that on
the high end where steam that gets them
is the lower Fidelity games and having a
little bit more battery life based on
your configuration I will give steam
that that and steam that got them on
interface it comes valve moving around
Pro like their UI is way better it
literally it's way better this this is
in the infancy stages and Microsoft and
windows 11 are gonna have to make an
official UI that is fully integrated
into this device so that that's about my
thing there I will say there's a feature
called rsr that allows you to um pretty
much when games don't have FSR you can
lower and put something at like 720p as
opposed to 1080p if you're a frame rate
guy if you want to get them 60 frames
and stuff like that you bring you you
activate that feature for a game that
doesn't have FSR and you can try to get
those frame rates that you want 120
hertz on this is insane I will say that
it's a shredded battery but it's insane
and last thing I'll say yeah no songs
Back well um key game I play
bro Forza five when this oh my God God
tear God here ridiculous oh I get
Destiny I'm a destiny guy being that
this is Windows it's not blocked by the
steam deck or the Linux OS amazing and
that's the not for a handheld no you can
play full-fledged Destiny and it is
playing exceptional so that's that I did
Diablo 4 had some tweaking there with my
settings now I got my frames up shout
out to kaibox who hooked me up with the
good settings on that did dbo at 120 20
Hertz oh pretty amazing you could do VR
on this as well a lot of stuff so look
oh I did that streaming on game the
death stranding on Game Pass what
preferred fields did you pick up for
because I I did you do the accelerated
mode yet
um which would be accelerated like that
I heard they like have some like boost
mode yeah when you plug in it's you
could go 30 Watts I'm all the way with
with the boosting on all that um yeah
this thing it's just it's a beast it's
an absolute beast when it comes to the
playing of games and yeah I'll let uh
soft jump in if he's back is it the Neo
Geo of handhelds
this is top tier I can see why Xbox got
behind the key the key difference is the
fact that I'm not just locked to Steve
first of all Stephen plays amazing on
this right but oh Steven Plays amazing
all your Steam games you log in you got
all your Steam games you play all your
Steam games no problem
that's crazy then epic game store I play
I think I downloaded Destiny over there
just to test it epic game store game how
that works so to stay up front but I got
a Diablo from Battlenet you know you got
Ubisoft EA Game Pass PC game pass I can
play Death stranding remember that's on
PC game that's exclusive on that and you
can download them local it's an amazing
streaming device if you want to stream
it's Wi-Fi six in this and you can
stream and it's amazing and you can save
battery life so that's the beauty of the
device it it has that functionality as
far as where how you want to play the
games where you want to play the games
and then the Fidelity is just top tier
it's a great device great um initial
setting just get through I send people
some tips and tricks if you're
struggling just moving around windows
with it and what settings to turn off
there's some settings that Windows has
in the background that can take away
from performance and there's some cool
Reddit things I can send but I'm
impressed it's about about a weekend I
can't stop playing it I take it
everywhere and the only I think I want
Ally bro you guys Gotta Have official
Doc license for yourself so that I could
get the ethernet because something about
the download speeds I think from a lot
of these store shops fronts are a little
slow that's it that's what I got oh so
I'm still is I'll go yeah if I'm taking
a phone call but uh yeah King you'll be
joining the the Allies we'll be getting
you to join and get one of your joints
in there you know that's a fantastic uh
uh Revelation
speaking to the I am banking out of
these back but uh saw quickly you know
your thoughts on it yeah it's not my
apologies
Father's Day food ordering drama no no
I'm good you're good
yeah so first impression when I took it
when I first got it unpacked it I was
like okay
aesthetically this is not as premium
looking of a thing as as the the steam
deck and the steam bed just looks you
know the you know the black console is
very Sleek even like uh ergonomically I
think it kind of feels more like a
controller than the rock Ally itself but
you know just looking at like the the
chassis and kind of the plasticy feel of
it and aesthetically I was not super
impressed off the rip right and then
when I looked inside the box I had to
laugh at this on the top of the the top
cover there's something that's that's
kind of placed in there what the heck is
this so I'll pull this out and it's and
it's like this cardboard stand it is
literally little Nintendo labo cardboard
stand so you can stand up your rock
right so it was at the event when I went
to the event that was what they was
using as a stairs
all right I'm not dude
I throw it on right and again as I knew
what was coming but I forgot so I go in
and I'm like oh no I forgot this is a
Windows 11 machine this is the windows
11 PC that's what it is right so what
does that entail that entails
a number of updates whether it be to
Firmware to specifically to the the
windows OS specifically to the AMD
drivers specifically to the Armory crate
uh front end so there's a lot of things
that need updates before you can even
really talk about playing games on this
right and then with Cog went and did
surgery put into two the two terabyte uh
nvme so that takes even longer so the
setup process if you're an impatient
person and you're not familiar with
Windows and working your way around
windows it can be extremely frustrating
it can be it could really really turn
you off if that's not what you're
expecting and shout out to Asus because
Asus if you go to their website they
have a number of different tutorials on
how to you know do all this stuff step
by step from the moment you unpack it
and telling you what you need to do so
it's very good about that but internally
in the box like when you in terms of
like instructions that they give you or
or on-screen things if you do not know
windows or
you don't really know what to do except
apart from whatever they prompt you to
do but it isn't intuitive right so it
doesn't really have a a console or or a
handheld front end like that Armory
crate is kind of that but it's not quite
there right so once you get past all of
that right and I I had to go through
like two bios upgrades one of them which
gimped my freaking performance I didn't
realize until after
um
so those are the growing pains when but
when you finally get down to the game
playing the options that you have in
terms of gameplay and the innards of
this machine which betrays the look of
it because the innards are are special
for what it is um for what it is there
are machines out there that are 1500
machines right the eye and Neo next and
things like that
um but again it's a 1500 machine as
opposed to a 700 Hot Topic
but this is they they uh I had a whole
they're fighting with you yeah yeah yeah
there's argument is Father's Day is get
out of there get out of there now like
I'm getting side eyes already too so I I
got a boogie
um let me just say uh what I was gonna
say about the um the PlayStation Cloud
thing real quick please let me set you
up um no just you set it up real quick
all right so real quick because this is
a combo yeah um Sony's starting the
testing of cloud streaming on PS5 games
PlayStation PlayStation Plus premium
members will eventually actually get
access to stream PlayStation 5 games
without having to download them to a
console and then on their official blog
we have very exciting news we're
currently testing Cloud streaming for
supported PlayStation 5 games this
includes Playstation Plus game catalog
and game Trials as well as supported
digital PlayStation 5 titles that
players own when the future launches
cloud game streaming for supported
PlayStation 5 titles will be available
for use directly on your PlayStation 5
console as a premium member and they
said we we it's important for premium
members to be able to enjoy as many
games possible via Cloud streaming as
more games continue to launch on the
PlayStation 5 console we look forward to
adding Cloud streaming capability for
PS5 titles in addition to PS3 4 and
classic titles already available for
members to stream okay okay well I mean
at this point in time it was supposed to
be a whole segment Buck was supposed to
come out and we were going to go into
how we invented the Internet we should
have just done that first yeah we should
have done it how uh you know it was a
real play on on Al Gore inventing the
internet and you know now that you know
we invented Cloud streaming and we're
going to start piecing it out to you
guys and allowing you guys to partake in
what we have invented
um it was going to go along in line
today I'm still going to give you that
skid I'll probably put that skit out on
Twitter and have some fun with that but
I'm seeing now how Sony is slowly making
that turn and making that uh bending
around the corner to actually meet where
we all are at right
um it's good to see that they will start
incorporating that into their their
system I'm making that an option I guess
they wanted to see how it worked for
Microsoft and other uh companies and now
this is something that they're pursuing
actively and openly yes all right uh it
will we'll get to that point where games
will be date and day uh hopefully they
can look at the game pass model being
that now you guys like how Game Pass is
right now
um and they can start doing the same
things as Game Pass listen
imitation is the greatest form of
flattery that's what all this is for you
and success dictates and predicts where
you will go right business-wise I think
you're a little bit slower foot but I'm
glad that you jumped on
uh now Cloud works right now cloud is a
thing right now uh streaming is a thing
now right this is something that we like
yet yes you said it like you got to give
kids the vegetables you're ridiculous
it's all of a sudden now it makes you
stronger right yes you like your milk
now right yes yes yes yes yes
okay I just like to watch you guys and
all your little stupid narratives flip
and fold and falls into you
don't want what y'all need because you
guys are stuck I don't like my stuff
screaming yeah I like my stuff native
and Sony would never do in fact right
Sony is doing all the stuff my Sunday
was gonna do to you and now you like it
right
yes yes
what was that cartoon it was it was
chilly Chilly Willy because they're like
he's like oh more pancakes
and then and then when he goes taking
the bite he's like no money no
that's a good one
the gravy
this time
of these cartoons like it's like
they've all forcing That Base to flip a
lot of the narratives that they were so
anti against and to see people have to
defend it is hilarious we would never
you know Shorty would never we value our
excuses over there we have never put it
in the service because that PC will
never PC getting it but but it's only a
year later we'll never stream you know
because streaming is
the property
you would do anything like there's
nothing that you won't do like you guys
is for the streets your show showed you
for the streets now Cloud streaming now
help help you're just gonna help help
it's looking stranger but you see people
some people are really panicking like
the Panic that's what we're used to yo
so yo shout out to this old way
he likes it he really
do your thing appreciate everything bro
about to beat my legs yeah go go do it
please no doubt Papa King in the
building you already know go back to the
wrong time yeah so that I mean again so
like I said once you get down to the
nitty-gritty of playing games and you
realize what the innards of this machine
could do
um I threw on the street fighter six I
threw on what the heck I threw on the
lies of P demo I threw on Jedi Survivor
oh you went for it and what else did I
do it what was your frames like what was
you doing on that so Survivor I got that
720. yeah I had a mess with the setting
song but you can get it to 60 if you do
if you you know do this in the 720 with
the uh the rsr also upscaling
um but the options you have to get all
of these games to higher frame rates
while still looking good
um it's impressive it's impressive and a
lot of it happens at the hardware level
right so you have software
implementation you also have Hardware
implementation you can just kind of
decide what stuff you want to do in
conjunction with one another or one
thing or another if you want to
sacrifice the the 1080p resolution to go
to 7 to 20p you have these upscaling
options or you could you can choose to
run 1080P and a lot of games will run at
60 but you can get that 40 sweet spot
again that that we were talking about
with the steam deck which 40 at that
screen size
um really does feel super super smooth
so you have a lot of options more so
than what the steam deck can provide you
in terms of the ability to run these
games at different sort of resolutions
and quality levels so it's super
impressive the fact that again it is it
is a Game Pass machine basically
now you can have your game pass stuff on
the PC natively in addition to all these
other storefronts that if you're a PC
Gamer you have them at the at the at
your hands right now right you can do
steam you can do Ubisoft you can do uh
you know uh what you would call that
epic epic everything everything is there
so it is it's impressive what it can do
it's still clumsy it's still and it's in
its infancy stages it will only get
better and the fact is because you have
that support from like a Microsoft and
because the price point is such where
this is a commercial product that you're
able to purchase at Best Buy My Hope and
my belief is that the support will be
there right so it's not like it's one of
these things that's going to get
abandoned you stop getting updates and
you know it's dead in the water and
stuff like that that's not gonna happen
with this which is what's super
impressive and interesting about it um
like I said there are more expensive
handhelds out there that are more
powerful but you're talking about twice
the price of this right
um so as the potential for a commercial
product to sort of break through even in
a way that the steam deck has
um simply because you know valve is not
really chosen to sell the steam deck on
anything other than their own sort of
platform you know really it's not out
there in stores so this is is super
impressive I'm excited to keep messing
with it because again they could they're
continuing to find ways to get a little
more juice out of it
um and you're gonna see some impressive
frame rates and some impressive looking
games uh for this screen size one gripe
another and I hate this no go for it I'm
mad I got these screens have too much
Bezel
give me the full screen experience I
looked at it I'm like damn it man this
mad bezel on here there's a lot of
unused real estate on the screen and it
makes me a little bit mad but I get it
you got to keep the price down a little
bit but again 120 hertz 1080p screen at
this price point is very very very and I
think for me solve it's like seeing this
screen right here having the ability to
have the game look at all the apps epic
games you you could play where you want
to play this is a huge that's the deal
for a guy like me who again is not
locked into the Steam OS I could play
where I want anywhere look at that bro
and then oh make sure you put it in
offline mode for guys if you're on an
airplane or whatever and windows you got
to put it in offline mode and then the
app will tell you hey you can put it
offline now now okay some games are only
online that I found out it's like a few
here and then the gears tactics was one
of them but everything else from the
steam you could put in like offline mode
um and a provider it's not like an
online game 90 so all the Game Pass
stuff you can do yeah I was doing um
what you call it can you Doctor rock
yeah but they don't they they need an
official dot you can use like
third-party docs for now and then I
would like that but uh yeah and I
actually tried um remote play uh
PlayStation 5 had a great experience
only thing is I'm gonna have to use um
other methods try to force the use of
PlayStation 5 controller externally
there's methods out there for people who
want to experience is that but um no
it's the same thing you can attach a
controller to you yes your Bluetooth or
whatever and you can use a you know an
external controller as opposed to just
using it as a as a handheld yeah no
doubt no doubt yeah those are one of the
questions I see but um yeah it was it
could only get better from from this and
I'll just transition to my thoughts on
King's topic which was
um yeah you know look Sony is being
aggressive with the streaming service
now it looks like they transition
transitioning into Cloud streaming which
would be huge for two reasons one
obviously yes the joke would be okay
yeah you copy an Xbox or whatever okay
fine but to me
you know what I look at is as much as I
like Remote Play
I it is janky remoting into my console
at home like what if somebody using the
TV like I'm literally going to dominate
from a remote location right whereas if
I could stream you know I could get it
streaming from their servers that's a
huge deal and then this helps the cue
light because remember we thought the
commute Q light was just uh a remote
only device that's huge if you can also
if you have a good internet connection
you don't have to log into your specific
console that I like so because to me
that's a little janky doing old school
you know doing that so I think that's
cool
um I will say I I have to think it's a
wrap for the partnership with with
Microsoft and Sony that Azure
partnership I think is in the bushes
completely I think because if you look
at um Sony's mentions remember that
because remember King was clowning we
had that top he's like look they're
hiring all these Cloud developers and
Cloud hires and all this other stuff but
if you look at the um job listings it's
all in AWS yes so that to me is an
indicator that that the partnership only
got As far as the talking stages I think
Jim Ryan said it he said we've just been
exchanging ideas I don't think that that
trade ain't gonna happen especially
after ABK and all the mud slinging and
the beef that's in the street that's a
wrap so I think that Sony will be
sticking with AWS going with AWS as far
as their streaming service and they will
be looking to expand I think it's decent
for them to put it in the premium tier I
wouldn't be able to stream my games on
to my allies so I'm all for this please
only get this done I'm a premium member
please I don't want to remote into my
console that's janky yes give me a
proper streaming option and for if you
gonna give me games that I own that I
could stream and don't force me to use
no PlayStation 5 controllers real fan
come on that's old school let me use
whatever device has the inputs that I
want to use on it please you know
Microsoft does not lock me into oh pull
out your Xbox controller and then play
the Ally no
yeah get your bird dogs on
yeah tight pants come in coming let's
get it oh man let's get it
wow that's different it's very very
different it's very different I
appreciate it I appreciate it appreciate
y'all for dealing with us all that stuff
helps the podcast it's because you
always we're growing seeing tremendous
you know growth and stuff like that so
yeah salute to y'all